all right well take a couple more calls
here we'll get to sort of what we can
six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty is the number whose on with
me next is Jeff from Fort Myers Florida
Jeff what's going on not much I had a
question for you guys yeah what is the
likelihood that you think that Donald
Trump would be a one-term president you
know I like to say that it's very likely
the problem is it is difficult when
presidents run for re-election to defeat
them I mean the power of incumbency if
you we know it exists with House and
Senate seats and it exists with
presidents as well so I think that the
most likely scenario where Trump doesn't
get another four years is that he
chooses not to run for reelection don't
you think Pat I mean it's tough to knock
off an incumbent president I'd have to
agree in a sitting president has never
chose it hasn't chose not to run for
reelection since LBJ in the 60s so is
that how far been a while yeah but I
could see him he'll be 74 years old I
could see him just passing the torch on
to Mike Pence and say well you know I
made America great again so I think my
work here is done
yeah it's pretty scary and and I hope he
chooses not to run again I think it's
also contingent on how much how much
further the unraveling of the Republican
Party is going to take place yeah that's
another issue also I agree because
there's curious about like reactionary
voter turnout in response to the 2016
results well yeah I mean I hope voter
turnout is higher than barely 50 percent
in 2020 because it was horrible I know I
we've got to see that people have to
vote alright Jeff thanks so much for the
call really really appreciate it